brilliant to be here at Croydon hospital
to see the great work of the doctors and
nurses here one of the priorities for my
government is going to be tackling the
covid backlogs and supporting the NHS
and what's going on here actually is a
fantastic example of what's possible
because of the way they're doing things
here differently elective activity is
now even higher than it was before covid
and look we Face lots of challenges as a
country but I am confident that we can
fix the economy and deliver on the
promise of the 2019 Manifesto including
having a stronger NHS and while I'm here
it's important for me to say to anyone
who's eligible please remember to go and
get your covert and flu Jab
you talk about fixing things uh how much
of a mess did Liz truss leave the
nation's finances in there's a talk of a
50 billion pound black hole
well I acknowledge that mistakes have
been made and part of why I'm now prime
minister is my job is to fix them and
I'm confident that we can the
Chancellor's already said of course
difficult decisions are going to have to
be made and I'm going to sit down and
work through those with him but what I
want everyone to know is that we need to
do these things so that we can get our
borrowing and debt back on a sustainable
path that's important because it means
that we can get a group of inflation if
we do that it means we can limit as best
as possible the increase in interest
rates which is important but as we do
that I want people to be reassured we
will always do it with fairness at the
heart we will protect the most
vulnerable and ensure that we can
continue to grow the economy in the long
run
why do you think it's more important for
you to stay here and supervise the work
of the chancellor rather than going to
cop27. well look I'm I'm really proud as
everyone should be about our record on
tackling climate change and particularly
with regard to cop I think everyone will
remember that last year we hosted one of
the most significant cops in recent time
and that was important because that what
we did there was set the Target and the
road map for the world to follow if
we're going to meet our climate
Ambitions and I think actually everyone
should also be really proud of how we're
doing we're one of the countries that
has decarbonized the fastest we now get
over half our energy from zero carbon
sources we pass a landmark law to
protect the environment and under my
government we're going to continue to
deliver on all of those things labels
say it's a massive failure of leadership
no it's the leadership that we have
shown on the climate is unmatched almost
along the world if you look at what
we've done in this country you know
we're an example for others to follow at
the pace in which we've reduced climate
emissions how we're going about
protecting our environment and those
things are really important to me it's
important to me that as prime minister
we leave behind an environment that is
better for our children and
grandchildren I'm very passionate about
that I'm very personally committed to it
and I just think at the moment it's
right that I'm also focusing on
depressing domestic challenges we have
with the economy and I think that's what
people watching would reasonably expect
me to be doing as well did officials
warn you not to reappoint Zoella
bravaman I think that the Home Secretary
has acknowledged the mistake she's
recognized she made a mistake she's
taken accountability for that and that's
the right thing now as I said in
Parliament earlier this week she raised
this topic with me when I discussed
reappointing her as Home Secretary and
I'm confident that she's learned from
her mistake you don't have any regrets
no I I said she's accepted her mistake
and learned from that and I'm confident
of that and what I what I do want to
know people to know is look I and the
Home Secretary are very focused on
delivering for them and that means we
want to cut crime we want to be tough on
criminals we want our streets to be
safer for our families and we want our
borders to be defended particularly
against illegal migration these are all
really important priorities for the new
government and that's what I want the
Home Secretary to be focused on and
that's what she's going to deliver
briefly we've had five prime ministers
in the last six years in 2016 we voted
to leave the European Union due think
that instability has anything to do with
brexit or is it that there's a
continuous Civil War in the Tory party
that is never going to be resolved I'm
confident that our party is United it's
United behind delivering on the promise
of the manifesto that we were elected on
with very strong support in 2019 you
know what's that Manifesto say it says
that we want to have a stronger NHS that
we want safer streets that we want
better schools that we want to protect
our borders and that we want to level up
the economy across our country that's
what unites and excites all
conservatives that's what excites me and
that's what I want to deliver for the
people of this country